[Music]
in my earlier book you wrote that there
there was a gentleman in GE came early
did evening work succeeded became
vice-president engineering got a bigger
job he began to falter his boss decided
to fire him but Jack wall said no he
intervened this is the great talent he
split the job in to give him portion of
it succeeded other portion was given to
another person who retired three years
later the jobs got combined later
well shad retired under Jeff Immelt this
man became the head of total GE R&D deal
with people as a resource not as a pink
slip on a Friday afternoon the basic
idea is people design strategies people
execute people before strategy people
before numbers people compete numbers
don't that was the central idea and that
in working in the companies the talent
and the people equation must be at par
or ahead in terms of timing with the
financial function today and in the past
most companies have paid too much
attention to finance numbers money but
they forget it's people who conceive
strategy who execute who deliver numbers
so we are saying the CHR owes the chief
human resource people need to be brought
up at the same power and at the same
time both CF on CH arrows need to work
as a team with the CEO to drive the
corporation's perpetuity its long-term
health and the competition is always
among leaders and people come
competition comes later g3 concept come
from my observations in a few companies
that actually say company has only two
resources people and money in most
companies they are in silos and they are
not together assignment of the right
people makes a big difference to hard
money to be allocated and how to
evaluate performance so g3 concept is
that the CEO and the CFO and the C HR o
three of them together really thinking
about the future assigning people and
the funds at the same time seeing the
interaction between the two when they
evaluating monthly quarterly annual
performance they should do it together
and see what is the diagnosis what is
the cause and together they should see
where the competition is going is
competitions talent is better or worse
are they assigned the right way are
there KPIs and compensation the right
way how does it compare with us these
two functions are relatively politically
neutral compared to other functions and
you break the silos between the two of
them now this is a different way to lead
to create value for customer and to
compete more effectively compared to
what we have done the first allocate
capital they do the numbers and then
later they talk about talent and people
assignment it should be together and not
separate in this radically different age
of digitization most of the work is done
by talent and we have three tools tool
number one is g3 CEO CH ROC F or
together should be doing the strategic
plan
because people create a strategy should
be doing capital allocation but capital
allocation must be done in conjunction
with people assignment a great person
assigned to a great job may use less
funds and create more value and three
the three guys together do the diagnosis
and do the replanting as conditions
change the stool number one to number
two in most companies is the concept two
percent of the key people have 98
percent of the concept 98 percent of the
impact this is a concept it's not
exactly 2 percent it could be half a
percent it could be 1 percent it's
throughout the company throughout the
geographies in all silos it's not by
hierarchy these people are the ones who
create value and others follow them and
number three is digitization tools
digitization of employees digitization
of all information and making it
transparent so that you don't
communicate through layers if we have 10
layers the information goes slow
distorted not fast enough so
digitization tools permit transparency
friction free flow of information and in
encourages motivation and creativity
[Music]
you